stop me if you think you've heard this
before
jews in germany are being warned against
wearing their kapaas
or skull caps in public chilling isn't
it
while the feared lurch the extreme right
in the european elections fortunately
did not materialize
there are parts of the continent where
being jewish could pose a threat to your
safety
indeed a european-wide survey in
december found
89 of jews feel anti-semitism has
increased in their country
over the past decade last year in
germany
violent attacks against jewish people
were up by more than
60 percent on the previous year now this
led to government commissioner for
anti-semitism
felix klein issuing with a warning this
capitulation is shameful it's thought
much of the problem is fueled by the
large numbers of immigrants arriving in
germany from mostly muslim countries
where anti-semitism runs rife and is
even encouraged in the young
someone once said the only thing
necessary for the triumph
of evil is for good men to do nothing
it is to be hoped germany is listening
this time
nobody could disagree with the
spirit of what you've just said nick
about
25 years ago i produced a report
which was entitled anti-semitism a very
light sleeper
because at that point we all thought
this is history it's all gone away
we all understand how terrible this is
but the research that we had done at the
time
suggested and unfortunately it's turned
out to be right that this thing
is still there and it takes many forms
as we've seen
across europe i think what you say is
completely correct this has to be called
out
and people who are people who are jewish
have to be supported the issue which i
have with simply saying that is that
if you are jewish it's not as easy as
that i mean it's you know it's fine for
the rest of us
to rhetorically go we support you and
all the rest of it
but we are not the people who on shabbat
have to walk
to the synagogue wearing the
and no matter how many times we come on
telly and say you know
don't do this we are asking these uh
people
to be heroic simply to
carry out their own normal rituals so i
think we have to do something a little
more than that i don't quite know what
it is you know
some part of me says we need to do
something showy like on shabbat
all men who might be jewish should wear
a skull cap so
that we're kind of saying to the bigots
distinguish which one of us is jewish
and
that may that's not going to solve the
problem but i think
we shouldn't be leaving it to the
victims to solve
this problem and before i bring you in
greg i need to declare i actually sit on
the advisory board of the cst which is
the organization that provides um
security
uh for anti-semitism and monitors it so
before anybody thinks this is
let's just get that out there great what
is this a role for government
it must be it must be but it's not just
government
it's good but there's got to be we
cannot allow it to happen
we're all scared of what we're seeing in
germany i think because
because of what happened yeah uh not
just germany though
no it's not just germany but a special
residence is a joke yeah there is a
special resonance for germany
uh and i think for someone in authority
to actually advise people don't wear
these because
you'll get recognized i think it's
terrifying that is
that does remind you of all those things
you've read and
seen about the 1930s in germany um
and we the rest of us who aren't jewish
have got to stand up
and get out there and join the jewish
community and say we are not prepared
how do we do that i think we might we
might require us to go on marches it
might require us to
but somehow we've got to say this we are
not going to put up with this
do you see the problem in britain as
well michelle well yeah i mean i think
with people watching this saying this
isn't just uh
to point you to a german um problem
we've got it people would argue about
the labour party and the leadership
there and all the rest of it and that's
a we could get into that and we'll still
be here in a week's time i imagine
but um i think it's quite interesting
it's absolutely terrifying
that you would not be able to go about
your daily business
because of a religion that you hold and
and for me
when you look at the statistics and i
was looking at how many synagogues and
how many jewish schools have
a guarded place outside of them in
germany something that we would take for
granted sending your children to school
without having
armed guards essentially at the gates so
i think what you've got to do is i think
you've got to be honest
about where is this problem coming from
because it is coming from different
areas it's
it's the far right it's all but it's the
far right it's the far
left and there's a lot of imported
anti-semitism in germany at the moment
and i thought it was quite interesting
one of the biggest german newspapers
what they did in terms of solidarity
they actually um printed on their front
page i think it was
it was almost like i don't want to say
cut out and keep because that's a bit
silly but
they actually did um a couple that they
said to people let's cut this out let's
have this
in solidarity and actually show people
that jewish people
should never hide away and especially
not in places like germany paper was
just built before i bring you in
rachel it's the labour party is saying
as you've mentioned it labour is fully
committed to the support defense and
celebration
of the jewish community is implacably
opposed to anti-semitism in any form
we reject any suggestion the party does
not handle anti-semitism complaints
fairly and robustly
or that the party is active unlawfully
and we will continue to cooperate fully
with the ehrc it is interesting to point
out it is only the second littered
organization
ever to be referred to the ehrc that
particularly committee and human rights
commission the other
being the bnp was the government one of
my
proudest moments putting them out of
business you helped do that did you
have
a government advisor or commissioner has
a duty to protect its citizens doesn't
he
so if he thinks they can't wear the
kippers they can't wear them yes or no
i don't think he can order issue a dick
tat to an entire faith as to
how they express their faith you know in
terms of symbols
and i think that i think
there was someone else in germany who
said no no we must carry on wearing the
yarmulke or the kipper
because we can't be cowed in the face of
incipient
fascistic tendencies michelle was saying
you know we need to find out where this
comes from and i think in germany you
know it is the far right but it is also
who are reacting they say to the ingress
of a million muslims
into germany over the course of merkel's
premiership
but that's no excuse and ditto they know
that we have to keep we have to go back
to the labour party that has imported
some anti-semitism from some of those
countries
and they must be honest well they are
claiming that it's muslim anti-semitism
as well which i mean
as well as far-right cemeteries but it's
coming at them from from both sides yeah
forgotten how key you were on this trip
because you you ran it wasn't the ehrc
in those days was it
it was the ehrc and we essentially
you know human rights commission and
essentially what we
said to the british national party is
you've got a constitution
which says that people like me can't
join can't do that in this country
good they resisted we took them to court
and bankrupted them so when you see the
labour party this only the second
politicalization to ever be referred
i think i think the labour story is a
different one and probably not for this
discussion
what i think is what i want the point i
want to make about this
two things one is um rachel's slightly
right to resist the point about muslims
but
because there have been three million
plus muslims in germany for many many
years
but i think what this tells us is that
there are different
traditions within islam and some of
those traditions or some of the
people who come from different
backgrounds as you say nick
do have a sort of ingrained hostility or
idea about
jews which they've grown up with which
is false and that takes me to another
point if you look at um
the numbers if there's been a survey
that asked people
about the holocaust and um what we found
is that 33 31
33.1 of people in europe
have not heard of or only know a little
about
the holocaust so this is where i would
start to be honest
there are people who have come to europe
and there are people who have grown up
in europe
who have no idea of the weight of this
issue and i think if the rest of us want
to do something
the first place we should start is make
sure that every single person
we know understands this isn't just a
sort of neighborhood dispute
this carries the weight of six million
deaths